hey guys welcome to spoiler party I've
just invited a bunch of my friends over
to watch the terrifying new movie
hereditary and we just got our socks
scared off of us
it was bonkers crazy so let's check out
what just happened
come on Peter yes your suit premiered at
Sundance it's been described as the most
traumatically terrifying horror movie in
ages tragic evil and so [ __ ] scary I
saw it yesterday I'm still shook by it
tensions are running high on set right
now why don't we go around the room and
do introductions and guys tell me
whether or not you like horror movies
I'm Trisha I've been a big horror film
fanatic since I was a kid I can't wait
this guy next to me kind of almost
sweating already Oh Garrett I hate scary
movies so mad I'm here we'll see okay
and I hate scary movies I'm not even
trying to suck up but May 24 makes
really good movies so I feel like if
they make a horror movie I'm going to
shoot my bed let me lie I only get
scared if I'm with someone that gets
scared we watched the original Jumanji
movie I was full of joy and Hugh what do
you guys think this movie is about after
watching the trailer Hobby Lobby project
gone wrong a grandma dies and they're
all sad and weird I think I'm really
scared about is like I'm going to find
myself in these characters so you're
afraid you're gonna find this movie too
relatable okay
I already want to throw us the treehouse
is the damn nice tree house
so far I'm doing okay
I don't want a hobby shame anyone but I
feel like if I walked into someone's
house and this was there I'd be like get
out if that dog dies the dog doesn't
know he's acting that dogs just walking
around no he doesn't know he's in I love
that yeah she could be the sweetest
warmest most loving person in the world
oh that dude probably doesn't know any
of those people he just goes to like
funeral homes
she was also incredibly stubborn I hate
noise all I couldn't see his Alyssa
Edwards whenever here they know oh yeah
like every straight person was like
right but he's gonna take care of me um
excuse me you don't think I'm gonna take
care of you
and the kid says but when you die you'd
be like honey that's not gonna happen
for a lot you know what I mean I don't
think that Charles has good intentions
with anything a kid says you're gonna
die and then just walk away like great
great and it was like how many more days
until you die oh my god let's say are
they banging poor guy look at his face
that's what you feel bad for him Anton's
everything else you have any experience
with paranormal activity oh yeah I grew
up in a haunted house man like me a lot
of years of my life I was a kid it was
the worst
oh my gosh the chocolates tearing up
though did she take the header the body
she took some head and she also took a
bite of chocolate I'm not creeped out by
the little girl at all she cut off the
bird's head but like kids are weird
people that are acting strange are the
adult the mom knows something that we
don't know yet yes she knows or
something weird and her family how scary
one to ten
that got me spooked a little bit yeah
took me to like a five I'm more curious
than scared right now
I'm like probably a sec random strangers
do terrify me where you at yeah where
everyone's at I'm sure too and it's only
because the tension just keeps building
I'm even more terrified for the dog now
after I saw what she did with the bird
you don't think she's gonna do that to
the dog could someone warn me so I could
close my ears and ice I hate long
hallways well when I grew up in a
haunted house it was like can we bring
experience back today can we talk about
that there was a little door that was
like the attic and you closed it no
matter how much you close it it still
opens like I moved out first to like go
to school my mom close up the house and
the last night she went to the kitchen
the middle of night she saw a little boy
everything happened in the kids room oh
sweet kids here to play with like Casper
no it's suck but you know if there's
ever that little boy there's something
else to get out of there let's see what
happens that yeah bring your dick where
were those parties at in high school
like they were not that cool
no he's horny as hell oh my god oh my
god
I did not see that coming that really
upset me you okay ma'am what just seems
like there might be something you want
to say yeah like what I mean why would I
want to say something so I can watch you
sneer at me sneer are you I'm never
sinner
Oh sweetie you don't have to you get
your point across don't you ever raise
your voice at me I am your mother this
is too much pent-up sexual frustration
pent up a lot of things going on that
don't you're sleeping on the husband
that's all I'm saying
and he's gonna come out and do this
somebody's sleeping springs that's not
okay I haven't seen one gay person in
this movie where's the represent you
know of I met a spiritual medium John's
a bad influence they were performing and
open seance I know I know what you're
thinking oh my god I hate chalkboard
don't chant anything you don't know a
minute that glass move I'll be out the
door I feel like that's a warning sign
Jones a little cray-cray can't be
dipping in the portal spirit world can't
be doing it and that is not sauce that
is like haunted demons I'm just getting
throwback memories of my childhood hey
it was talking about how she was nervous
that she was gonna relate to this movie
too much but I feel like you it's
bringing a lot back and I don't like it
how scared are you guys right now we
have four or five man it's ramping up I
can't put my finger on the handle of it
and it's gay and handle on the finger
that I don't know it's okay that wasn't
a number but thank you I'm at at seven
I'll say I'm at a fire
I know she's got the tools to really
start it's not really quite Jumanji
level scary yeah I think they have
escapes right now and Jumanji those kids
can't escape they could just drive to
New York City all this stuff happens in
the woods where there's no witnesses
where it's all far away where people get
crazy ideas in their head I think I'm
very clear about this I would move to
New York City this movie keeps picking
and prodding you and you keep going up
it's almost like a series of like small
moments I feel so bad for the dad ah
Steve did not sign up yes for year 20
you could be a sucker for a wounded bird
but then eventually you have to be like
okay is this sustainable I think that
dog pieced out of this for sure yeah
[Music]
next hit dance movie you guys are
[ __ ] crazy people
Jesus Christ overall how scared were you
I got pretty spooked towards the end so
usually if I go in a fight stance that's
how I know I'm pretty shook it I would
say it got to an 8k I'm more mad at what
I'm mad that it was scary so scary plus
I don't know maybe like I'm trying to
talk myself out of being scared right
now so I want to say Oh process this
better than that family was processing I
did what I want to squash it I would say
it's like an eight or nine you handled
it very well though for how scared you
were going in yeah I thought it was
going to be much out of you worse I feel
like it was probably like in seven or
eight overall I feel like peaks at like
an eight if I were in a theatre I think
I would have been much scared or how
about some hereditary Mad Libs
hereditary is the blank movie of the
year what would you describe it as chic
demonic movie of the year is a spooky
[ __ ] up parenthesis that's like smiley
face movie of the year I just think of
the amount of dicks that were in there
oh it's the most big heavy movie you've
ever seen dick reporting happy oh not a
lot of it but about you if you guys were
possessed by anyone in the world dead or
alive who would you want to be possessed
by I would do Oprah she knows what to do
with her own body he's on this great
spiritual journey do it for me girl I
would choose the rock he's gonna go to
the gym like 18 hours a day I'm gonna be
Jack Sun dolphin or Ceylon miss you I
must was like the logical conclusion if
it wasn't it Garrett who do you peg some
like French chef that suddenly like able
to cook so well oh I already kind of
look like her I feel it would be like oh
I kind of dress like her - I'm so sorry
Ellen yeah if you're not dressed like
thanks for watching spoiler party and
shame your pants with us as we watched
hereditary make sure to LIKE the video
and also comment below what movie you
want us to watch next
[Music]